- [Voiceover] Let's see
if we can give ourselves
some practice evaluating expressions
that have two different variables in them
So let's see if we can
evaluate the expression
seven J plus five minus eight K,
when J is equal to 0.5
and K is equal to 0.25.
So why don't you try to pause the video
and evaluate this first before
we work through it together.
Alright, so if we want
to evaluate this thing,
everywhere we see a J we
want to replace it with a 0.5
and everywhere we see a K
we want to replace it with a 0.25,
so let's do that.
This is going to be seven times,
and instead of J I'm gonna put a zero,
a 0.5 in there.
And then we have plus five
minus eight times K.
And K we're saying is 0.25.
0.25.
So what is this going to be equal to?
So if I were to take,
if I were to take,
and I can color code this,
seven times 0.5.
Half of 7, that's going to
be three and a half, 3.5.
Then I have plus five.
And then I'm gonna subtract.
I am subtracting eight times 0.25.
0.25, this is 1/4.
I could rewrite this if I want.
0.25, that's the same thing as 1/4.
Eight times 1/4, or another
way to think about it is
eight divided by four is
gonna be equal to two.
So this whole thing over here
is going to be equal to two.
So it's gonna be minus, we
have this minus out here,
so minus two.
And what is this going to be?
Well, let's think about it.
3.5 plus five is 8.5,
minus two is going to be 6.5.
So this is equal to this,
is equal to 6.5.
Let's do another one of these.
Alright.
And we'll, just like before,
try to work through it on your own
before we do it together.
Alright, now let's do it together.
So over here I have this expression 0.1 M
plus eight minus 12 N,
when M is equal to 30
and N is equal to 1/4.
Alright.
So everywhere I see an M I
want to replace with a 30.
And everywhere I see an N I
want to replace with a 1/4.
So this is going to be equal to
0.1 times M.
M is 30.
Times 30 plus
eight minus 12 times N,
where N is 1/4.
N is 1/4.
So what is,
what is
1/10,
This right over here,
0.1, that's the same thing
as 1/10 of 30?
Well 1/10 of 30, that's going to be three.
So this part is three.
And we have three plus eight.
And then we're gonna have minus.
Well what is 12 times 1/4?
That's gonna be 12/4,
or 12 divided by four,
which is going to be equal to three.
And now when we evaluate this,
so that is equal to this,
we have three plus eight minus three.
Well, threes are going to,
you know positive three, then
you're gonna subtract three,
and you're just going to be left with,
you're just going to
be left with an eight.
And you're done.
This expression when M is equal
to 30 and N is equal to 1/4
is equal to eight.